as we get into the late high on period
you start to have the emergence of a
increasingly powerful warrior class and
all of that comes to a head in the year
1185 when the high on period ends and a
general by the name of
minamoto yurotomo comes to power and
what's significant here is the notion of
an emperor continues to exist but all of
the power resides in what you can
essentially consider a military dictator
or a shogun and the system that emerges
is known as
the bakufu system or the shogunit and
minamoto yortomo was the first shogun so
you can see here the emperor still was
there but the shogun was where all of
the power was and this is really the
beginning of medieval japan
it's the beginning of
the kamakura period named for where the
capital of the kamakura period was
now it's distinctive about medieval
japan and the bakufu system is that it
becomes much more decentralized than
what we had under the heian period it's
often called a feudal system because it
has parallels to what was going on in
europe at around the same time where at
the top you had this military ruler the
shogun and then beneath the shogun you
had this decentralized structure of
these lords essentially that controlled
significant regions of japan they were
called the daimyo and there were roughly
300 daimyo
in japan roughly county-sized districts
and the daimyo in order to conquer land
or to protect their own land they would
support a warrior class known as the
samurai and so they would take their
agricultural surplus from their lands
and use that to support this warrior
class and this warrior class of samurai
they were analogous to knights in
medieval europe and just as the knights
had chivalry in europe the samurai in
japan had bushido which eventually
emerges as their code of conduct despite
that decentralized nature they were able
to fend off invasions from kublai khan
so as we've mentioned in other videos in
the 1270s kublai khan is conquering much
of china and he also attempts to conquer
japan this right over here is a picture
of the mongols shooting arrows at a
samurai warrior now one of the key
factors that keeps kublai khan from
taking over japan is on two different
occasions as they send their boats from
what we now consider to be korea to
japan they encounter significant storms
that destroy most of the boats and so
the mongols who are able to get to land
are significantly depleted and they're
pushed back by the samurai warriors
now the kamakura period continues on
until 1333
when there is a brief only a few years
restoration of the power
of the emperor but a few years after
that
another shogun comes to power
and that is ashikaga takaoji
and this is the beginning now of the
muromachi period
the muro machi period is often known as
the ashikaga period or the ashikaga
shogunit but it's named muramachi for
the district of kyoto at which it had
its capital
and even though over the course of the
muromachi period the emperor at
different points was subsumed into the
power of the shogun this is considered
especially the later muramachi period as
one of the more fragmented times of
japanese history you had many
civil wars you had a lot of internal
conflict and it was only at the end as
we get to the end of the 16th century
that japan gets
reunified and one of the key factors
that allows it to get reunified is that
in the middle of the 16th century
portuguese traders show up and they
introduce
guns to japan
and one daimyo in particular is able to
take significant advantage of those guns
and that is
oda nobunaga ora nobunaga as i mentioned
was a powerful daimyo one of these lords
who controlled what you can kind of
consider to be a county
of japan and using these guns he's able
to
put most of the other daimyos most of
the other lords into submission and he
begins to significantly unify japan now
he is eventually assassinated and his
successor toyotomi hideyoshi continues
to unify japan even further
when he dies
tokugawa ayasu takes power and he's able
to consolidate even further and
definitively becomes the ruling shogun
of japan
now even though this period that we're
entering the edo period and it's named
for the castle edo from which the
tokugawa shogunate ruled even though
this continues to be a shogunate with a
shogun in power at the top the bakafu
system the reason why this is considered
the beginning of the modern period or
the early modern period is that japan
was finally unified again
now one thing that we will see as we get
into the 19th century as we get into the
end of the ido period and then you have
the meiji restoration where you have
imperial rule again is that japan is
very good at borrowing technology and
ideas from other cultures and then
making it their own
we saw that in the classical period
where they imported ideas of
confucianism buddhism imperial
government from the chinese but adding
their own flavor to it
and we will see it again as we get into
the 19th century when japan is one of
the first countries not just in asia but
in the world to truly industrialize by
learning many of the technologies that
get pioneered in the west